The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
J. KIM VANDIVER: If I wanted
you to remember three equations,
really commit them to memory,
that'd allow you to essentially
do everything that we've done,
they'd be the following three.
The first would essentially
be Newton's second law.
We use that all the
time, and in vector form,
summation of the external
forces on a rigid body
must be equal to the
time rate of change
of the linear momentum
of the rigid body.
And that we know is equal to
its mass times the acceleration
of its center of mass with
respect to an inertial frame,
and this slash o means with
respect to an inertial frame.
That's Newton's second
law, and of course we
use it all the time.
Now Euler added to what
Newton worked out for us.
And let me actually just
point out over here.
So P with respect to
o then is M velocity
of G with respect to the
inertial frame-- vector,
vector, vector.
OK, what Euler taught us
was that the summation
of the torques about a point
A is the time rate of change
of the angular momentum
with respect to that point
plus the velocity of the point
cross P with respect to o.
So that's our general
equation for angular momentum
and [? R ?] for torques.
And remember, H with respect to
A is the cross product of R--
how do I want to write this guy?
I don't want to save that.
So we define angular momentum.
It's just a cross product of
the distance from the point
that we're at to the-- I
didn't write this right.
This is A with respect
to G cross P o,
so that's our general
definition of angular momentum.
And finally, the third
equation is the one
that I showed you last time,
which does appear in the book
but not until you
get into chapter 21,
and that is that you
can write H with respect
to A as H with respect to G plus
[? RG/A ?] cross P with respect
to o.
There's something wrong here.
Matt, what have I done wrong?
MATT: Do you want a
sum that will give you
the angle [INAUDIBLE].
J. KIM VANDIVER: Yeah,
it just slipped my brain
because I don't do it.
I don't think about this.
This is the-- yeah,
it's a summation.
There we go.
In general, this is
a summation, and it
is the location of all the
little particles i with respect
to A cross the linear momentum
of each particle [? mi ?] Vi
with respect to o.
And we add all that up,
that's the definition
of angular momentum.
And we generally for
rigid bodies then
reduce that to saying that
it's a mass moment of inertia
matrix computed with respect
to A times omega x, omega y,
omega z.
That's how we
generally express this.
But the third equation I
want to come to is this one.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: That's
not [INAUDIBLE],
but it's not really with
respect to A in general.
[INAUDIBLE]
J. KIM VANDIVER: This is i
with respect to A. Let's just
do this because I've just
slipped a bit this morning.
OK, I'm thinking too much
about where I'm going here.
This equation I
introduced last time.
The book doesn't make a
big deal about this at all,
but it's really a
fundamental equation
that we proved from scratch
very simply last time.
And this equation allows you
to solve lots of problems
without even, for example,
knowing the parallel axis
theorem.
It'll just get you through it
even without knowing things
like that.
So with these three equations,
you can do all the problems
that we've done, and I'm going
to do two or three examples
this morning, and
including coming back
to a discussion of the
parallel axis theorem.
OK, so these three are the ones
I recommend that you remember
because everything else
will flow from-- we know,
like, we have special cases.
So when A is at
G, then this just
reduces to H with
respect to G. When
there's no vel-- when A doesn't
move, this term goes away.
Those are all special
cases, which you can just
substitute in the numbers and
discover for yourself if you
don't remember those.
But these are the
three equations
you want to have
in your kit to use.
So last time, I kind
of classified problems
in four different
classes depending
on the simplifications.
And the class 4 problem
was the more general case,
and that's when the point A
is allowed to move in general,
and that last
equation we had can
be very handy in those cases.
And I mentioned a problem last
time, but I didn't work it out.
And that's simply
this problem, where
you've got a block,
maybe a box on a cart,
and you're
accelerating the cart.
At what point will
the block tip over?
So this one I've put
a nail right here,
so the block can't slide, but
it will tip about this point.
So if I accelerate it
slowly, nothing happens.
If I accelerate it fast enough,
it tips around that point.
So that's the key.
Identifying the point's have
the work, so that's the key bit.
What's the greatest
acceleration that I can have
so that this block will
just not quite tip?
That's the problem.
If you didn't have
the nail there,
there's also the
possibility that it'll
slip without tipping over.
OK, so that's another
problem that we'll
address at another moment.
OK, so let's do this
problem quickly.
So this is our problem,
and I've got a handle here,
and I'm pushing on
it with a force.
I've got a couple of wheels.
This is M1.
This is M2, and I'll have
an inertial frame here X, Y.
So the question is
what's the maximum force
that I can apply such that
the block won't tip over?
And I've got a little nub there,
so this thing can't slide.
OK, and this is my point
A because that's the point
I expect it to rotate around.
The X, Y, and Z is
coming out of the board.
OK, so Newton's second,
so we apply it first.
From Newton's second
law, we say the sum
of the forces, in this
case, on the system.
By the system I mean M1 and M2.
We want to remember that you
can collect things together
at times.
So the sum of forces on
the system, in this case,
is then M1 plus M2, and it's
the acceleration of that point,
and in this case we are just
going to do in the X-direction
because we know that's the only
one where there's any action.
So the sum of the forces
in the X-direction
is the total mass of the
system times the acceleration
in the X-direction.
So the X double
dot we're looking
for is F over M1 plus M2.
So this we're trying to find out
what the maximum value for this
is.
Now next we can apply
the torque equation
because that's the key one.
And that's the sum of
the torques-- now it's
just on the box-- at
with respect to point A.
And we can say, well,
looking at that,
we need a free body
diagram now of our box.
You've got an M1g down.
And you might have a normal
force upwards, generally,
but now we want to
think about where
are the forces going
to be acting on the box
when it's just at this point
that it's just barely about--
just barely starts to tip.
So we're hypothesizing
that here at A, there'll
be some upward force, right?
And it's going to take care
of the static equilibrium,
but it also could enter
into our moment calculation
if we weren't clever
with respect to where
we calculate this point.
So the sum of the
torques about this point,
we don't have to bring
this one into it.
We do have to consider this one.
So the [? R ?] here cross that
force, so we get a moment, Mg,
and I need some
dimensions on my box.
We'll call it b and a height h.
So the moment arm,
this axon is b/2,
and it's in the minus
[? z ?] direction,
so I get a minus M1g b/2 k hat.
Those are my external
torques on the box
because the normal force
supporting it on the floor
is acting at A now.
And this must be from
our second formula,
dH with respect to A/dt
plus the velocity of A
with respect to o, cross
P with respect to o.
And P with respect to o
was [? M1VG ?] with respect
to o, all right?
So we need to know what
is the velocity of A
with respect to o.
But we're only allowing
motions in this direction.
This has to be evaluated
in the inertial frame,
so we have a coordinate X here.
So it's going to be
some X dot, and I'll
give you a capital I
hat just remind you
that's in the inertial frame.
What is the velocity
of G with respect to o?
AUDIENCE: Would it be the same?
J. KIM VANDIVER: Yeah.
You know, in this
condition we're
saying we want the block
not to quite tip over,
and that means it's moving
with the cart at exactly
the same velocity,
so it's the same.
It's also equal to
A with respect to o,
but if that's the case,
what's the cross product
between velocity of
A with respect to o
and G with respect to o?
Ah, so that one goes to zero.
That's because of this.
OK, so that leaves
us with-- we don't
have to deal with
these terms, but we
do need to compute
H with respect to A.
And now I'm going to use this
formulation because it makes
this problem easy
to do and not have
to deal with parallel
axes or any of that.
So I'm going to use
my third equation,
and it says that this
is H with respect
to G plus RG with respect to
A cross P with respect to o.
So you notice I chose this
problem kind of on purpose
today because I started
saying, here's three
really important equations.
We use all three
to do this problem.
OK, so now we're
exercising the third.
So my block here,
since we're dealing
with angular momentum
of rigid bodies,
I now have to think in terms
of a coordinate system attached
to the block, and
I'll formulate it
so it's lined up the same way.
So this is a x1 I'll
call it, y1, and z1.
But x1 and big X, these
are in the same direction,
and so is z and z1
and capital [? E. ?]
And that means that my I
hats are the same as the unit
vectors associated with my
coordinate system attached
to the body.
Remember, this is this
body-fixed coordinate system
that allows us to compute
moments of inertia,
and I'm going to have
this located at G, OK?
So the only rotation that
we're allowing in this problem.
This is basically a 2D
planar motion problem.
It could conceivably
have x and y translations
and a z rotation
constrained in the y,
so it has possible
rotation and translation.
So the only omega we're
considering is this omega z,
and so we'll proceed
to use it to compute H.
So we use this formula.
So H with respect
to G is-- just I'm
doing a couple of these
things sort of carefully just
to remind you of where
these things all come from.
This is I with respect to G,
and in this case, 0 0 omega z.
And we come out of
this then the only--
are these principal axes?
So if they are, this
is diagonal, right,
so I've located these through G.
Taken into consideration
the symmetries,
I know because the symmetry
of these are principal axes.
Therefore, this is a diagonal
mass moment of inertia matrix,
so when I calculate to do
out the multiplication,
I get Izz with respect
to G omega z k-hat.
There's only one
vector component of H
that comes out of
that, and that's Hz
is that Izz G omega z k-hat.
And there are two other
possible components of H,
but they're both 0.
There's no other rotate--
there is no angular momentum
in the x- or y-directions.
OK.
[? RG/A ?] in this problem
is from here-- this
is point A-- two there, so
RG respect to A is b/2 i plus
h/2 k.
It's the location of just the
position of G with respect
to A. [? b/2 ?] over
[? h/2 up. ?] So in order
to complete my
calculation of H of A,
I need to get the second piece
of the [? RG/A ?] cross P/o.
So [? RG/A ?] is my
b/2 i plus h/2 k cross.
And then my linear
momentum is M1 x1 dot
in the i hat direction.
And it'll either be a
capitalize I or a lowercase i.
They're the same, all right?
So this is my second
term the RG cross
P. i cross i, these two--
this pair gives you nothing,
so it's k cross i is j, and
so you get Izz with respect
to G omega z.
And then a k term
from here M1 h/2
x dot, and it's also in the k.
And that's my total angular
momentum now with respect to A.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
J. KIM VANDIVER: And I think--
just a sec-- k-- you're right.
Wait a second.
k cross i should
give me a j, right?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
Professor?
J. KIM VANDIVER: Yeah, k cross
i gives me a positive j, right?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[? AUDIENCE: RGA ?] should
be a positive j based off
of your [INAUDIBLE] system.
J. KIM VANDIVER: Ah, yeah, yeah.
This is a good catch.
All right, so what happens now?
Now we get j cross i,
gives you a minus k.
Now that should be OK,
and let's see if that
agrees with what I wrote here.
Yes, they did it
right in the paper.
Just couldn't put it
right on the board.
So now the sum of the
torques with respect to A,
we've already figured out
that it's minus M1 g b/2 k
hat must be equal to
the time rate of change
from our second equation dH dt.
And we've already figured out
that the second term goes away.
So it's just then the time rate
of change of that expression.
Oh, I think we could
probably do it straight away,
so the time rate of change,
the derivative of this,
you get omega z dot.
You get an x double dot.
The k doesn't rotate, so there's
nothing that comes from that.
If you take that
time derivative,
you get Izz with respect to
G omega z dot minus M1 h/2
x double dot, and these are
still all in the k direction.
And that's an
equation that only has
k hat terms on the left
hand side, k on the right,
so this is just one potential
component of the torque.
And so we can drop
the k's at this point.
And we now have an expression
for the external torques
in terms of the
accelerations of the system.
This is essentially theta
double dot [? if it ?] tips,
and that's the
linear acceleration.
But now then the
key to the problem
is we're trying to find
out when just at the point
it might tip but doesn't, so
what's omega dot-- omega z dot?
OK, so what we're looking
for we let omega z
dot or require that to be 0.
I mean this makes
this even simpler,
and you find out then
that M1 g [? b/2 ?]
equals M1 h/2 x double dot.
And I have to add minus
signs on both sides,
so I got rid of them.
And the M1s go away, and I can
solve for h for x double dot,
and that's going to be g b/h.
OK, and we started off saying
what's the maximum force?
So this is now x max,
the acceleration maximum
and the force maximum is
just equal to M1 plus M2
x dot max for-- and let's
see if that makes sense.
If b and h were equal--
that's sort of a common sense
argument here-- b
and h were equal,
that tells you that you could
accelerate 1g at 1g-- just 1g
and that makes sense.
The Mg here is [? putting a ?]
restoring moment down of the MG
[? b/2. ?] And the
acceleration of this is putting
an overturning moment on it in
the other direction that would
be Mg [? h/2, ?] and if
h and b are the same,
then it would be exactly 1g.
Now so that's the
answer the problem.
If you want to do live
dangerously from the beginning,
you could have done this
with a fictitious force.
I just mention in passing
I'm not recommending
that you generally go there.
This was a very straightforward
way of doing it.
We just started with
these three laws,
and we just worked our way
through the problem and all
the way to the end,
and it fell out.
If you didn't want to
live dangerously though,
you could say that when
you accelerate this,
you can think of there being
a fictitious force that
is equal to minus the
mass of this object
times the acceleration on the
center of gravity of force
that is pulling it in
the other direction.
So you could think of there
being a force M1X double dot
opposite to the direction
of the acceleration.
This is minus the mass
times the acceleration.
It's the fictitious force.
Here's your point A.
Here's gravity M1 g.
This is the distance b/2.
This is the height h/2,
and you could say just
at that moment of balance,
the sum of those two moment
should be 0-- the sub
of the external torques.
And you would end up
with a M1 x double dot
h/2 minus M1 g [? b/2, ?]
and you come up
with the same answer.
But for most of this that
takes a real leap of faith
to do that to convince yourself
that you're right, right?
You got to know
a lot of dynamics
and remember all
the parts and pieces
to be able to just go there.
But if you do it just carefully,
those three equations,
it'll all worked out.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Why is
omega z [INAUDIBLE]?
J. KIM VANDIVER:
Because as long as
the condition satisfied
that it doesn't tip over,
what's the rotation
rate of this block?
AUDIENCE: 0.
J. KIM VANDIVER: 0.
So we're not solving for
dynamics in this problem
of the thing tipping.
It isn't rolling on us.
We're coming just
up to the point
that it tips, and say we're
not going any farther.
And so we just require the two
moments-- the one essentially
caused by the acceleration,
this fictitious force, that's
got to be just in equilibrium
with the restoring moment
provided by Mg.
That's essentially the
problem we've worked,
but we've done it really
carefully just using
these three laws.
And the real problem though if
you didn't have the nail here
is if now if you need
to test your solution,
could you ever actually reach
that rate of acceleration
before the thing
starts sliding on you?
And, you know, maybe not.
This thing slides
before it tips, OK?
AUDIENCE: Would the fictitious
force take into account M2?
J. KIM VANDIVER:
Take into account M2?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
J. KIM VANDIVER: So
the angular momentum
was all calculated with respect
to the rigid body M1, right?
The only reason
M2 entered into it
this is the way things
happen in real life.
It's just a real problem.
It's a box on a cart, and
is it going to tip over,
and you're pushing on it.
How hard can I push?
To do that problem you
just have to consider
these to begin with so
that you realize that,
oh, the acceleration involves
both of these masses,
but the angular momentum
part of the problem
involves only the boxes tipping.
So problems even as simple
as this one looks has
their little
complications, and you've
got to work through them.
So just so we had to treat
the body as a two-body system
to start with, and then look
at angular momentum for just
the box.
AUDIENCE: Does the
pin or screw exert
a force on the [INAUDIBLE]?
J. KIM VANDIVER: Yes,
absolutely, mm-hmm.
Does it create a moment?
No, and that's why we
don't have to consider it.
I could have put it in there
and probably should have.
If I had done a free
body diagram here,
you could still say that there's
a reaction force upwards here.
And I'll call it Ry and
another one this direction
I'll call Rx.
And when computing moments about
this point, neither of them
enter into the problem.
And that's why we like to do
our calculations for angular
momentum with respect to points
around which the body rotates
because that allows
us to not have
to solve for those unknown
forces that pop up there,
so yeah, indeed there
are forces there.
OK, got it figured out.
So we've talked a little
tiny bit about parallel axis
theorem, and so I'm going to
consider this a slender rod.
I can spin it about one of its
printable axes and calculate
its angular momentum
of whatever I need,
and if I move it over to an axis
that's-- I just move it over
by a little bit.
Let's say this is the
x-axis here in my body,
and this is the z,
so it's at omega z.
And I move my point and around
which I am rotating over
by a small amount A, and that's
this distance between these two
holes.
And by parallel axis
theorem, we could say, well,
now there's a mass moment of
inertia with respect to A,
which is the mass moment of
inertia with respect to g,
which is [? Ml ?] squared over
12, if this is the length,
plus the mass times
this distance squared.
We know how to do that.
But now what happens if I take
this stick, my slender rod,
and here's my original x, y, z.
And I want to move it,
my point A, my stick now
I'm going to move it over by an
amount a and up by an amount c
so that it's now up here
with respect to this point.
So this stick has
been like this,
and now I'm going to then
rotate it about that.
That's the simple case.
Now I want to rotate
it about this axis
when it's moved
over to like that.
So not only have I moved it--
so here's the original problem--
like this, but now I move
it up and over-- maybe
I'll do it there--
and now I spin it.
And I'm interested in angular
momentum about this point,
so now it's dynamically
unbalanced for sure.
This thing is trying
to wobble, and it's
been pushed up and
over, so is there
a way to get-- how do
we solve that problem?
How do we compute the
torques for this problem?
Well, we could try to go
at it with parallel access
to start with, but you don't
know how to do that in general
for this problem.
So what do we go to?
We go back to those
three equations,
and just start there,
and it'll all fall out.
I'm going to do this kind
of briefly for this problem,
so I want to compute H with
respect to A H with respect
to G plus RG with
respect to A cross P.
And now this is [? RG/A ?]
is this vector here,
that position vector, OK?
And the only
rotation is omega z.
This is our z-axis.
So I can write this as Izz
with respect to G, 0, 0,
omega z plus my [? RG/A ?] cross
P/o, and that in this problem--
let's get the vector
right this time-- it's
a in the i direction plus
c in the k direction cross.
Now we need to know what's
P with respect to o,
but that's just the velocity
of this so the center of mass,
which is now here.
The velocity is omega
cross r, so when
you do that-- you've done
that problem lots of times--
it's this distance, so
perpendicular distance
[? across ?] k.
It's got to be
going into the board
if it's spinning like this.
We know the answer's
got to come out plus j,
and it's r-- it's A omega z in
the j-direction cross Ma omega
z, but it is in the
j hat direction.
That's your linear momentum,
and this is [? RG/A ?]
cross with a linear momentum.
This here is M velocity of
G here with respect to o.
That's this term, so we
carry out this calculation
and we get-- and I need a j, OK.
So i cross j gives me
a k, so I'll get 2,
and this is a diagonal
matrix because we
began with a set of
principal axes for our stick,
so this term is Izz
with respect to G.
I shouldn't have written zz
here, just i with respect to z.
We multiply this out.
We pick up just this term omega
z k hat plus i cross j is k,
so that's Ma squared omega
[? zk, ?] and k cross j
is minus i minus M ac omega
z in the i hat direction.
So this is my angular momentum,
and reminding, it is a vector.
This has got components in
the k and the i directions.
I've rewritten it here.
This also could be written--
this H with respect to A
is I with respect to A
times the rotation vector.
If we had just set
out with this problem,
and said we're going-- if we
know the mass moment of inertia
matrix computed with
respect to this point
and multiplied it by our
rotation rate vector,
we should have gotten
the same answer.
So we didn't do that.
We just worked it out
using just this formula,
but we've essentially
discovered the answer.
This is the rotation around k.
This is the Izz term
with respect to A,
and it really looks like the
familiar parallel axis piece.
It's the amount that you
moved this axis over,
and the axis you're spinning
around, you moved it over A.
And you know the parallel
axis theorem just
says add Ma squared, and
you've got the answer.
But we also moved it up,
and it gave us another term.
What do you suppose
in that term is?
So this is Izz with
respect to A, this term.
By parallel axis theorem,
you're familiar with it.
This one is I, and
this is xz with respect
in the A coordinate system.
OK, we've created-- we've
made this thing unbalanced.
The angular momentum
vector no longer
points in the same
direction as the rotation.
It has a k component
and an I component,
and sure enough, when I
spend that thing like that,
I feel that additional
torque out around my hand
down here where I'm holding it.
This thing is going-- trying
to pull it back and forth.
So we have essentially
just shown--
we have just arrived at a
more complicated parallel axis
theorem by just using
this basic formula.
So Williams in the dynamics--
that second handout
from Williams has actually
given us a general formulation
for parallel axis theorem.
So this is just handy to know.
I'll just give it to you, and
if you have a problem some day,
where you just like to go
directly to this statement,
so now I'm just going
to say, in general, we
could have moved over by
A, up by c and actually
into the board by b, so x,
I'm moving A. y, I'm moving b.
z, I'm moving c.
OK, so you could have all those
possible moves of the new point
about which you're rotating.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: For the [INAUDIBLE]
matrix i with respect to A,
does that mean that you're
rotating about point A?
Or what is it--
J. KIM VANDIVER: You are
rotating about point A.
AUDIENCE: OK.
But isn't point A just
the [? immersion? ?]
J. KIM VANDIVER: Let me think.
I'm trying to
think of a good way
to-- when you
started this problem,
we're spending about the
middle-- about G, OK?
And we can calculate
angular momentum
of this object with respect to
G and learn some things, right?
But now we've built
a different device.
This is an object now that
is, in fact, spinning.
Let's imagine it's a
fan blade, and you've
broken one blade off.
The motor is here.
A proper fan blade would
have blades on both sides,
so it's nice and balanced.
The shaft has some
length and it sticks out,
and now you break off
one of the blades.
And so you have a system
that's doing this,
but this is going to put a lot
of unusual loads on this point
down here.
So it is rotating at the same
rotation rate about this point,
but it is now a system whose
center of mass is over here,
and it's up.
It's above this
point, and it's out
from this point,
the center of mass.
And now you compute the angular
momentum with this point,
and take its time
derivative, you
will find all the torques
required to make this happen.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
J. KIM VANDIVER:
A little louder.
AUDIENCE: The movement A,
[? i-hat ?] Mc [? k-hat ?]
[INAUDIBLE]
J. KIM VANDIVER: Movement that
you've moved the center of mass
away from this axis of rotation.
And you've moved it up and over.
So actually, let's think
about that for a minute.
This is our beginning
point, right?
We're at G. If I just move it
up, does it cause any problems?
It's still balanced,
and you'll find out
that nothing's happened
in this problem.
H with respect to A is
the same as it was before.
But now you move
it up and over, it
starts causing complications.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] H of A
equals [? A ?] times omega z.
So i doesn't have
like direction,
but you have an [? ixz ?]
terms and [? xc ?] term,
and you're multiplying it by
a vector with an omega z term,
so how are you getting
an i hat from that?
J. KIM VANDIVER: OK, so
I haven't gone into this,
and I'm not going to.
The [? i ?] matrix is a
thing called a tensor.
And so this is a
convention that you
can make it a very mathematical
and assigned unit vectors
to each of these terms inside,
but I haven't done that.
But the convention here is that
this, the H, angular momentum
is a vector.
It consists of three components.
It has three potential vector
components, Hx in the I,
Hy in the j, and Hz
in the k directions.
And we, in a compact form,
say we can express that
by multiplying its mass
moment of inertia matrix
with respect to A times the
vector that is its rotation.
And I only have one
component of this omega,
but it is in the k direction.
And when you take this vector
multiplied by the top row, that
gives you everything that's
[? I. ?] You multiply
this vector times
the second row,
it gives you everything
is in the j direction,
and the result is part
of Hy in the j direction.
You take this vector, and you
multiply it by the third row,
it gives you the
z-directed components, OK?
So this one, because
when we multiply this out
what's in this matrix--
is this matrix diagonal?
No way.
And we move it, and we've gone
and done something strange
here.
It's not diagonal,
and when you multiply
this times this top row,
there's a term here,
which is not 0--
shouldn't write 0.
Make an x here.
This times this gives you an
omega z times that in the i hat
direction.
OK this term comes from
there being something there.
OK, and I'm just going to give
you a generalization that you
can go back and read the
Williams handout, which
he says, if you want to rotate
about some fixed point A.
Then you can say
that this matrix
is equal to the one with
respect to G, which in our case
is diagonal.
The original one that we
had doesn't have to be,
but if you pick principal
axes, this will be diagonal.
Plus M b squared plus c
squared minus ab minus ac.
It's symmetric.
This is a squared
plus c squared.
So if we're rotating
a system if you
know its mass moment
of inertia matrix
with respect to G [INAUDIBLE]
perhaps principal axes,
and you want to rotate
it about any other point
where you've moved it
by an a, by a b, by a c,
this is essentially the
general parallel axis theorem.
And you can just plug
it in and use that.
And you can see what
would happen in this case
if you multiplied-- if you
add these two together,
they add term by term.
This goes into this point on.
This one adds to this,
so in this problem,
in our particular
problem, this becomes
you have an Ixx, Iyy, Izz
with respect to G terms.
It's diagonal to start with,
and then in our problem
that we did there,
we didn't have a b.
No b terms, so the
b terms are all 0,
but you do end up with a
minus ac term over here.
And if you multiply this by 0,
0, omega z, see what happens.
You get minus ac
in the I direction,
and you need an M here.
And you come down here,
you get the Izz G omega
z in the k direction, and
that's those two terms.
Here they are.
Yeah, oops, I need the
plus [? A ?] squared.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: When you move it
over to the end of the stick,
normally like you're just
shifting it parallely,
but now there's gravity.
Is that why you have
those little things?
J. KIM VANDIVER: Say again?
AUDIENCE: So normally,
if you just take a stick
and you have a
principal axis and you
can't move that
parallel to the end,
you wouldn't get
all of this but--
J. KIM VANDIVER: Yeah, and if
you just move it-- so yeah,
I'm glad you asked
that question.
So normally the types of
problems in which we usually
use the parallel axis
theorem is you've
been spinning it
around one axis.
It's a principal axis,
everything's fine,
and you want to
just move it over,
so we do that when we
do pendulum problems.
Here's the thing
around the center,
and we just want to know,
how does this thing behave?
When we move it up here,
it becomes a pendulum,
and we would like to
compute the angular
momentum around this point.
We say, oh, we've
moved it a distance d.
The new mass moment of
inertia in the z direction
is the original plus
Md squared, right?
So when you only make
one move, you only
have an a, a b, or a c.
You never get any of
the off-diagonal terms
because their products, see?
But if you start
doing more than one,
you've introduced
complications, and that's
part of the reason
I put this up is
there's limits to the simple
parallel axis theorem,
but there is a general
way of doing it.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I believe her
actual question involved
what causes the torques?
Is it gravity?
For example--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I
was asking why--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
J. KIM VANDIVER: Ah, so what
causes these torques when
you have two?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
J. KIM VANDIVER: OK, we've
talked about this a little bit
before.
When we calculate
the angular momentum,
it never involves gravity.
Never gets in there, not in the
angular momentum expression.
So when you go to compute d, the
time derivative of the angular
momentum, you will
not find torques
that are caused by gravity.
You just can't do them.
It's not part-- but are the
torques in the System I mean,
why just hold this here.
There's [? Mg ?]
down, and there's
a static moment caused
by this thing trying
to twist this down.
When you sum the
torques-- when you
do the sum of the
torques in the equation,
you do your free body diagram,
that term will appear.
But it is balanced by some
physical torque over here
that balances it.
You just won't find it
from doing [? dh ?] dt.
It's just part of the static
equilibrium of the system.
AUDIENCE: But the reason
when you move the pen over,
the reason you even have
the shift is because of
[? gravity? ?]
J. KIM VANDIVER: No, no.
So she's asking if is
gravity the reason you--
I'm not even quite sure.
AUDIENCE: How did you shift the
z component of your [? plan? ?]
J. KIM VANDIVER: OK,
so let's just make
this a real physical problem.
I'm making an airplane engine,
and I'm making an airplane
with a propeller on it.
And the bearing that
supports the propeller shaft,
if I put it really
close to the propeller,
OK, then it's doing this,
and everything's fine.
What if I extended
the propeller shaft?
OK, so now the
bearing is back here,
and now the propeller spins.
Does that cause any torques, any
loads back here on the bearing
because I've extended it?
No, and you could prove that
just by going through this.
You do [? dh ?] dt, and you
find out the only torques
when it's nice and
balanced are those required
to drive this propeller
in the direction
of the axis of rotation.
But as soon as you do something
to that propeller, like you
mount it off-center,
which rarely happens,
but if you dinged--
if you broke off
the tip of one of the
blades of this propeller,
you'd now have a propeller
that looks like that, right?
And now, even in
the original system
if your bearing is right
close, this is spinning around,
but is it putting a load?
Sure there's a
centrifugal force that
is going around and around.
It has nothing to
do with gravity,
nothing at all to
do with gravity.
OK, just because you now have
the mass centers out here,
it has momentum, the
time rate of change
of that linear momentum
is a force making
this thing going in a circle.
OK, now if I extend
the propeller shaft
so it's like that, and I
foolishly designed my airplane
so it had a long propeller
shaft sticking out there,
if there's a little bit of
unbalanced in this blade
so that you're not spinning
about the mass center.
You're spinning about
some other point.
Now that centrifugal force
going around is pulling
is trying to bend this back
and forth around this bearing.
And because of the way in which
we formulate angular momentum,
if you formulate
it about that point
and take its time derivative,
it will reveal those moments.
It's really amazing that
it can do that for you,
but it has [? zero, ?] nothing
to do with gravity, OK?
So handy, hard to remember
this from just a blackboard
presentation, but it's in that
second reading by Williams.
He does it in a
very-- he proves it
in a very simple way using the
summations of the MI [? RI's ?]
and so forth.
Proves it in a very simple
way, but a very general
handy formula that you can use.
OK, so let's have another topic,
which I'm not going to do.
We've got a few minutes.
You have [? money ?] cards.
We've been thinking about that.
And let's ask questions, yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
J. KIM VANDIVER:
Where did I the--
AUDIENCE: The plus [? MA ?]
squared and the plus A squared.
J. KIM VANDIVER: Ah, I was
doing that kind of fast,
and I probably
even messed it up,
so let me check the-- so I
was doing for the example
that [? RG/A ?] equals-- we
moved it over by ai and up
by ck, so and plus 0j.
We didn't move it in
the j direction, OK?
So this is my amount
that I've moved it.
I've moved it an amount
a, and an amount c.
So the Williams
formula would say, ah,
that new mass moment of inertia
matrix with respect to a
becomes the original plus--
and now every place there's
a b here, it goes to 0.
And the remaining
bits I add with those,
so I should get a M--
whoops, this is a c squared,
no second term.
The third term is minus Mac.
Over here, that one is 0.
This one becomes a
squared plus c squared--
AUDIENCE: --minus [INAUDIBLE]?
J. KIM VANDIVER: Minus, yep, M.
And this one is minus Mac 0 Izz
and a squared plus b squared,
so it's just a squared.
So this is now correct.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
J. KIM VANDIVER: Pardon?
AUDIENCE: Times M
in the bottom of it?
J. KIM VANDIVER:
Yeah, all of these
needs M. Ma
squared's M, M, M, M,
so that's our problem
when we did two shifts.
But a second we shifted
it in two directions,
we get these
off-diagonal terms, which
means that if you are actually
making this device rotate
about point A, you will get
these unbalanced moments--
this dynamically unbalanced.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Will we be trying
to find our [? mass ?] moments
of inertia directly, or should
we just do [INAUDIBLE] equation
and have them fall out like
the integral with x times y
[? vM? ?] [INAUDIBLE]
J. KIM VANDIVER: He's kind of
asking advice in whether or not
we ought to be trying
to find the inertia
matrix about other
points, right,
like [? the I ?]
with respect to A.
Where I started today,
I said you can basically
do all the problems with
these three equations,
and this doesn't mention
parallel axis theorem.
We use this to find, in
fact, to solve this problem.
We didn't talk parallel
axis theorem at all,
it just-- the
answer dropped out.
And if we looked
into that careful,
we could generalize that.
We could work now with
that a bit and say, ah,
there's a pattern to this.
I'll bet this can be recast
like this, and it can.
So if you know this
exists, and you
don't want to have to
grind through finding
these terms that
come from here, you
can do the problems by finding
the mass moment of inertia
matrix with respect to A.
You can use this form only when
you have fixed axis rotation.
The thing is the point
A is [? about ?] which
this rotation is occurring, then
you can write down the formula
this directly like that.
So you that got to be
careful when you apply
the parallel axis theorem.
The nice thing about
these three forms
is they're generally true.
Point A can move.
Point A can be accelerating.
The problem that we did here,
point A is accelerating.
Not only moving, it's not
even an inertial frame.
We solved this problem-- this
is a non-inertial frame problem.
We went right at it and
solved it directly, OK?
So I would say, if you have any
doubt to answer your question,
when you're in doubt
just use the formula.
And then you will need to
find moments of inertia
with respect to
the center of mass,
and it's in your interest to use
principal axes because they're
easier.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: If you were
to say [INAUDIBLE]?
J. KIM VANDIVER:
Ah, so if you took
the derivative of
this, [? dh ?] dt,
this one just gives
you omega z dot.
That's you're spin in the
direction of rotation.
This term, that
unit vector rotates.
This gives you two terms-- gives
you an i term, omega dot i,
and it gives you an
omega j term, OK?
And what those are,
those are two torques.
This problem, there's
a torque caused
by the centrifugal
force trying to bend
this in the j direction.
And if this is accelerating, you
know, a theta double dot term,
there is a torque trying to
bend this thing backwards.
OK, get them both.
All right [? money ?] cards
and see you on Thursday.
Thursday we're going
to do a nasty problem,
and it is it a lead
in to a problem.
You can do the same problem
extraordinarily easily
using energy.
And that's kind of the
purpose of doing it,
so you see both
ways of doing it.